allerdings gab es terror hinweise zum
beispiel haben mehrfach marokkanische
behörden gewarnt
am riesei zitat ein anhänger des und
führe ein projekt aus gut wenn man da
zwischen den zeilen liest hätte man
eventuell aber was sollten 40 deutsche
behörden insgesamt waren am fall amri
dann es war der totale wahnsinn hier die
staatsanwaltschaft duisburg zum beispiel
wollte amri wegen sozialbetrugs
reinkriegen schreibt ans bundesamt für
migration die antworten wissen wir noch
nicht wo der ist dann wählen sich die
duisburger in oberhausen wo er schon mal
abgewiesen worden
antwort keine ahnung ja dann schreibt
duisburg an den kreis kleve in dem ambri
gemeldet war antwort nach zwei monaten
wer weiß es keine ahnung richtig
kriegsherr und im oktober frack duisburg
dann beim lka nordrhein-westfalen nach
die hätten jetzt den kollegen sagen
können dass am lied zu dem zeitpunkt im
knast sitzt in ravensburg wegen pass
fälschung dann hätte man da nur
abschiebehaft draus machen können haben
sie aber nicht und weil keine papiere da
waren ja weder aus kleve noch aus
tunesien haben sie in wieder
freigelassen werden was auch sie können
wahnsinnig schlecht malen
gehören silver ist das problem am ende
fühlt sich gar keine mehr verantwortlich
wie in einer wg
wenn sie mit 16 käfer in einer wohnung
wohnen und theoretisch müsste jeder mal
das klo saubermachen
wie sieht es dann aus der
hauptangeklagte in diesem fall ist
niemand anders als der verdammte
deutsche föderalismus
da müssen wir ran nicht an irgendwelche
fußfesseln warum hat bei uns jedes
bundesland einen eigenen geheimdienst
verstehe nicht sogar bremen immer bremen
dann werden jedes jahr drei
fischbrötchen geklaut entschuldigung
herr hering aber unser föderalismus hat
sich doch durchaus bewährt quatsch 16
bundesländer sind mindestens 14 zu viel
wir machen deswegen dem alten jetzt nur
noch zwei aldi nord und aldi süd
überzeugt noch nicht gut dann sag ich
jetzt mal folgendes ohne föderalismus
wäre dieser mann nur noch ein einfacher
rentner in münchen dabei
[Applaus]